Back in the day using a computer
monitor was dangerous business.
It meant sitting without
flinching while an electron gun
shot charged particles at your
face at nearly the speed of light.
Only to have them slam into a thin
layer of glass covered in poison.
Depending on where and
how many electrons were shot at you,
they would produce explosions of
different colors and brightnesses.
Which your eyes would see as
an adorable paperclip, or whatever.
This system is called
a cathode ray tube, and
it was the bane of LAN
parties everywhere.
Since the screen is a big rectangle, and
the electron gun can only paint
one dot of color at a time,
the gun had to traverse the whole
screen many times a second.
Well I'm sure you can think of many
cool space villan curves that would
get the job done.
The chosen solution was a lot simpler.
The chosen solution was to divide
the screen into horizontal scan lines.
Much like the lines in a book.
And the traverse the lines
from top to bottom.
This was called Raster scanning.
>From the Latin Rastrum, or rake.
It's like raking a zen garden, but
instead of having a rake with many tines
you have to draw each line individually.
The roster scan implies that
the colors in the screen have to be
laid out in a rectangular grid.
While this might seem obvious,
it didn't necessarily have to be so.
You can certainly imagine
a hexagonal grid of colors, and
that might well have been better from
a human perception point of view.
Turns out though that the math
of drawing to a hex grid is
super frustrating, so maybe it's best
we stuck with rectangular grids.
So ultimately, for a computer to draw
it constructs a two dimensional array of
colors and memory and ships those colors
to whatever device is going to be
ultimately displaying the colors.
Be that a monitor, a projector, or
some sweet virtual reality device.
Note that these roster elements are also
referred to as picture elements, or
pixels, for short.